chào các
bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn cái
thao tác với đối tượng testb hay còn gọi
là văn bản con thì đây là đối tượng
tbx Đối tượng tbx thườ này thường nó nằm
trên một cái khung và chúng ta dễ dàng
thay đổi kết c và chúng ta dễ dàng thay
đổi vị trí của nó trong vò bản chúng ta
đặt đâu cũng được và trong cái bài này
ngoài cái thao tác với đối tượng tbx thì
chúng ta còn thao tác với hai đối tượng
đó là Quốc ác và đội tượng picture ha
chúng ta bắt
đầu chúng ta chọn dòng sau đó vào Insert
chọn word á rồi chọn
kiểu chúng ta thay đổi kích
cỡ và sau đó chúng ta chọn hiệu ứng cho
đối tượng
worda chúng ta chọn word Sau đó vào set
format
chọn effect và chọn
transform Sau đó chúng ta tìm đến cái
mục cái hiệu ứng mà chúng ta cần định
dạng
rồi chúng ta đặt vào nó vào một vị trí
phù hợp tiếp tục chúng ta sẽ chèn đối
tượng hình
ảnh chúng ta vào Insert chọn picture
chọn z device
và chúng ta chọn hình sau đó
Insert sau khi chúng ta chèn hình xong
thì thao tác đầu tiên chúng ta C phải
nhớ đó là Định dạng vị trí chúng ta nhấp
vào layout
option và chọn
Square chúng ta tiếp tục thay đổi kích
cỡ của đối tượng hình ảnh và chúng ta
quan sát cái việc bố trí cái văn bản và
hình ảnh trong cái file chúng ta đang
làm nó khác với cái file binh hóa đây
chúng ta quan sát nó khác Đấy là do cái
Định dạng vị trí của bạn Cái Định dạng
vị trí bên này là định dạng Square còn
định dạng bên này là định dạng tha và
chúng ta đổi sang định dạng tha bằng
cách nhấp vào layout option chúng ta
chọn định dạng t ở
đây đây rồi và bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thực
hiện tiếp cái thao tác đó là
chúng ta sẽ tạo đối tượng
textbox như cái hình minh họa thì để tạo
textbox chúng ta có hai
cách cách một là nếu chưa có nội dung
thì chúng ta sẽ vào Insert chọn
testb chọn draw
testb sau đó quét lên trên vă bản và
chúng ta tiến hành gõ nội dung
vào trường hợp đ đã có nội dung như
trong bài này cái đoạn này là nội dung
chúng ta cần đưa vào testb này nha
trường hợp đã có rồi thì chúng ta thao
tác chọn đoạn văn cần đưa vào testb vào
Insert chọn textbox và chọn draw textbox
đây Bây giờ chúng ta chỉ việc thay đổi
kết
cỡ và thay đổi vị trí bằng cách nhắp nó
kéo nó lên ở vị trí trong vòng B
đấy thao tác tiếp theo chúng ta có thể
thực hiện đó là chúng ta định
dạng cái màu sắc cho đối tượng tbox này
thì định dạng màu sắc cho đối tượng tbox
á là nó có hai cái màu màu của đường
viền và màu nền thì chúng ta sẽ thao tác
như như sau chúng ta chọn test bx chúng
ta vào set format và chúng ta sẽ trọ vào
mục là SH Style này này chúng ta nhập
vào cái nút này Quick size chúng ta có
thể chọn một trong kiểu các kiểu
này tuy nhiên chúng ta muốn định dạng
riêng cho mình thì chúng ta sẽ vào set
field màu nền chúng ta chọn màu
Nền màu nền này có thể nó pha màu giống
như ở ph minh họa thì chúng ta thao tác
tiếp chúng ta chọn set field chúng ta
chọn
gradient và chúng ta chọn kiểu kiểu đâu
đó ví dụ chọn kiểu này nó n ná giống như
trong bài Bình hóa
nhập tiếp tục trong kiểu này nó lại dùng
nhiều màu sắc cái này màu vàng sáng này
đến màu trắng này đến màu đà này thì
chúng ta tiếp tục vào set field chọn
gradient và chọn more
gradient và cái nút giữa này này à chúng
ta sẽ chọn màu
trắng được chưa tiếp nuốt bên trái là
góc dưới nè chúng ta sẽ chọn cho nó một
cái màu đậm hơn một chút tươi hơn một
chút đây Có thể là chúng ta chọn cái màu
nó đó
màu hơi trong minh họa là nó hơi ngã qua
màu vàng một chút đây tiếp tục
ở góc trên này này chúng ta chuyển sang
cái màu khác thì nhấp chuột vào và chúng
ta nhấp chuột vào cái nút này Đây này
đây chúng ta chọn màu cho
nó đấy và các bạn quan sát Này cái nút
màu trắng này chúng ta có thể dịch
chuyển và các bạn quan sát trên đối
tượng t bx này này khi chúng ta dịch
chuyển cái nút màu X màu trắng này này
nó sẽ thay đổi cái vị trí này à
đây thì đó là cách chúng ta pha màu
trong cái đối tượng tbx
này tiếp tục chúng ta tiến hành là kẻ
khung cho đối tượng textbox thì mặc định
nó có khung rồi nhưng chúng ta muốn màu
sắc và nét đơn nét đôi hay đường không
liền nét như thế nào đó thì chúng ta
chọn textbox vào save format chúng ta
chọn tiếp
là set outline là đường viền nhấp và
chúng ta chọn way
độ đậm nhạc ha chúng ta chọn das đường
không liền nét hay chọn kiểu này nhiều
kiểu khác nhau tuy nhiên là chúng ta có
thể ví dụ chúng ta chọn một kiểu đi
chúng ta chọn kiểu không liền nét như
thế này
đây tiếp tục chúng ta chọn cho nó đậm
hơn một chút màu màu sắc khác thì chúng
ta chọn rồi M
L qu nha quay Rồi M L tiếp tục chúng ta
sẽ chọn là color màu Ví dụ mình chọn màu
đỏ
đấy và tiếp theo là quyết độ rộng đậm
hơn một chút đấy và dưới này là các cái
kiểu ấ các cái kiểu rồi Kết thúc và
chúng ta hoàn tất cái thao tác với đối
tượng
tbox Xin chào các bạn